[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour l'émission dû 7 8 échos votre
magazine d'actualité économique du
territoire
pour ce premier numéro nous sommes à la
ryder cup au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines focus pour
cette édition sur les retombées
économiques de la compétition mondiale
de golf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire de cette édition
saint-quentin-en-yvelines capitale
mondiale du golf avec à la clé des
opportunités économiques importantes
attirer des entreprises sur le
territoire trouver de nouveaux
investisseurs l'occasion aussi pour les
sociétés saint-quentinoise de rencontrer
des partenaires l'open innovation et
l'open data au programme d'une
conférence organisée au ski kubel a
rassemblé plusieurs personnes du milieu
économique et universitaire de
l'agglomération reportage à suivre
enfin vous retrouverez l'écho en bref un
retour sur l'actualité économique du
mois de septembre sur le territoire
avant de s'intéresser à l'impact
économique de la ryder cup
revenons sur cette rencontre organisée
au ski cube le 20 septembre dernier des
échanges entre différents acteurs
économiques de saint quentin en yvelines
sur l'open innovation et l'open data
regardez la mise en place de l'open
innovation et l'open data dans une
entreprise la thématique d'une rencontre
organisée au ski cube partage des
expériences notamment avec le groupe
segula spécialisée dans l'ingénierie et
le développement de projets industriels
une entreprise basée à trappes est
implantée dans 26 pays
l'open innovation pour nous c'est dire
est une façon à mode de travail qui nous
permet un d'accélérer l'innovation et 2
d'augmenter en compétences rapidement
l'innovation c'est aussi une animation
j'irai pour pour stimuler collaborateurs
et recueillir leurs idées donc une
autorisation le permet aujourd'hui créer
un réseau entre ses salariés ses clients
ou d'autres entreprises le principe de
l'open innovation une pratique mise en
place chez renault exemple avec les open
innovation lab un travail avec des
acteurs externes au groupe au losange
c'est le fait de dire qu'on va
rassembler autour d'une même table des
acteurs qu'on va plaider qu acteur et
qui vont construire ensemble des
solutions
vous avez
df vous avez plein de start up et de
grosses entreprises qui se rend compte
sur un même sujet là en l'occurrence et
la mobilité et ensuite la deuxième chose
si vous avez les creative lab c'est
plutôt les labels interne et la cde je
dirais de l'open innovation interne
parmi la trentaine de participants
nabila ali ingénieur en génie civil
à moyen terme il souhaite créer son
entreprise en développant un outils
destinés au btp avec des enjeux autour
de l'open innovation et l'open data
c'est une problématique qui est ressenti
par les territoires que ce soit des
communautés d'agglomération ou des
entreprises et c'est une question qu'il
ya de plus en plus importante et qui
nous touche nous particulièrement dans
le btp prochain rendez vous au ski cube
le mardi 9 octobre à 17h30 pour la
welcome party une soirée pour découvrir
les services offerts par le territoire
inscription obligatoire auprès du ski
cube
trois cent mille spectateurs sont
attendus ici pour la ryder cup
près de 70 personnes par jour et parmi
eux des chefs d'entreprise et
entrepreneurs français et étrangers
venus profiter de la compétition et
aussi faire du business pour saint
quentin c'est une opportunité deuxième
pôle économique d'île de france c'est
l'opportunité d'attirer de nouveaux
investisseurs sur le territoire à
travers des rencontres avec des
dirigeants d'entreprise reportage
rencontrer et partager son savoir-faire
l'intérêt des rencontres business et
golf organisé par saint quentin en
yvelines
pendant la ryder cup plusieurs
entreprises du territoire ont présenté
leurs innovations comme le groupe segula
avec ce navire fluvial écologiques
fonctionnant au biogaz et à
l'électricité ou encore supra wade et
son transport urbain du futur
nous en profitons pour consolider des
contacts pour nouer de nouvelles
relations avec les partenaires du
territoire ce soit des industriels des
écoles des centres de recherche et
développement pour construire des
opportunités à venir
en sept ans
un lieu qui qui me permet de rencontrer
des partenaires qui peuvent compter dans
notre histoire nous avons vu par exemple
de deux sociétés d'ingénierie comme ak
et segula qui ont des capacités de
propos porte est
la connaissance et l'art un certain
niveau qui peuvent aussi faire des
prestations d'ingénierie précise
mobilité du futur smartcity aerospace
sécurité défense et santé les secteurs
d'activité majeur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la ryder cup
l'opportunité de tisser des liens entre
les entreprises du territoire et aussi
de détailler ses forces pour attirer de
nouvelles entreprises et de nouveaux
investisseurs un événement comme cela
génère une population d'entrepreneurs
donc de contacts économiques très
intéressant pour saint quentin
donc bien sûr on reçoit beaucoup de
décideurs mais je dirais que c'est des
entreprises
pas seulement française les entreprises
européennes même voix de tous les coins
de l'europe
les entreprises américaines aussi il ya
aussi des asiatiques
je sais que ces américains et et contre
l'europe aujourd'hui mais on a on a bien
sûr beaucoup de gens d'autres pays même
qui ce qui du coup s'intéresse au golfe
viennent ici et puis nous entreprises
françaises il s'agit de nouer des
contacts peut faire comment on fait ici
dans la loge c'est se donner
l'opportunité de parler des atouts de
territoire les atouts de la ville les
atouts de la france en fait leur
expliquer qu'on a là à côté de nous le
plateau de paris saclay qui est
aujourd'hui après un plateau qui a joué
un rôle clé dans cette renaissance de
l'esprit d'entreprise en france panure
outils la pdg du groupe finlandais
konecranes spécialisé dans les
équipements industriels est venu
rencontrer les acteurs économiques de
saint quentin en yvelines
cette entreprise réalise 3 5 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et
recherchent un lieu pour installer un
centre d'intelligence artificielle avec
un critère précis compétences être assez
proche d'une université qui peut nous
aider de pouvoir trouver les personnes
aussi du de l'université
ce coup de projecteur sur
l'agglomération grâce à la ryder cup va
renforcer l'attractivité économique du
territoire
déjà fort de ses 16 mille entreprises 17
mille étudiants et de ses 4 6 millions
de mètres carrés d'immobilier
d'entreprise autres entreprises
présentes lors de cette ryder cup est
implantée sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines plus précisément aux
clayes-sous-bois c'est à tous
société spécialisée dans la
transformation numérique et je suis avec
cyril giraudeau responsable marketing
bonjour bonjour alors vous avez présenté
plusieurs objets que vous créez à atos
dans la loge de saint quentin en
yvelines
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en dire plus
vous êtes venu avec notamment c'est ça
donc
atos est une entreprise de
transformation digitale et on est
capable de faire à la fois des services
mais aussi des produits et voilà
l'exemple c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui en termes de cyber sécurité
des téléphones
renforcer en termes de sécurité
logicielle avec la possibilité de passer
des appels de façon confidentielle et
des données d'échanger des données aussi
et puis aussi des dispositifs de ce type
là qui permettent l'accès sur des sites
sensibles
c'était quoi l'objectif en présentant
ces objets lors de la ryder cup dans
cette loge de saint quentin en yvelines
alors l'objectif c'est une démarche
gagnant-gagnant avec la ville de saint
quentin qui nous a fait l'opportunité de
preuves de présenter nos produits à des
ad au tissu économique local mais aussi
internationale dans le contexte de la
ryder cup c'est donc là une possibilité
de faire du bizness d'une part et puis
aussi de montrer l'attractivité du
territoire de saint quentin
puisqu'on y implanter et qu'on a une
démarche active sur place quelle était
la stratégie d'atos lors de cette ryder
cup
troisième événement le plus regardé au
monde et puis on voit beaucoup de monde
des touristes à la fois français et
étrangers venir
quel est l'objectif pour atos dans cette
ryder cup saisir cette opportunité de la
ryder cup c'est cette opportunité c'est
c'est une autre façon de faire connaître
à tous forcément nos clients nous
connaissent les personnes du secteur de
l'industrie de lighting connaissent mais
peut-être pas le grand public c'est une
occasion aussi de pouvoir se faire
connaître au delà des limites
habituelles
vous allez rencontrer notamment un pdg
d'un groupe finlandais
qu'est ce que vous avez pu lui dire
qu'est ce que vous comment vous avez
échangé qu'est-ce que vous avez échangé
je crois qu'on a trouvé des points
d'intérêt commun aujourd'hui il a des
problématiques liées à l'industrie 4.0
on a des solutions
qui nous permettent de proposer des
services autour de la maintenance
prédictive avec de l'intelligence
artificielle du big data
donc là on voit qu'il ya vraiment le
besoin et le l'offre qui se rencontrent
quelles peuvent être les retombées
économiques comme pour un groupe comme
atos lors de cette ryder ryder cup
je pense qu'on a des retombées moyen
terme dans les contacts qu'on pourrait
avoir business et puis après il ya des
choses un peu plus long terme par
exemple on
on s'implique dans le territoire local
on va travailler avec la ville de saint
quentin sur des aspects de filières de
recrutement ces cyber sécurité puisque
c'est un sujet l'emploi local donc des
choses qui sont à l'horizon 2 1 ou 2 ans
si je remercie et on poursuit cette
édition avec l'écho en bref le nouveau
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité de guyancourt a ouvert
ses portes début septembre un site de
douze mille mètres carrés très atelier
plusieurs formations proposées comme la
vente ou la maintenance des voitures des
motos ou encore des vélos la ministre du
travail mme muriel pénicaud a assisté le
6 septembre dernier à la rentrée des 500
apprentis accueilli pour cette première
rentrée
le fait de faire un campus je crois
beaucoup c'est vous vous trouvez en même
temps déjà apprentis du ca paix jusqu'à
l'ingénieur des personnes en formation
continue en réinsertion des personnes en
situation d'handicap des filles dans
l'automobile toutes les diversités
toujours à guyancourt l'inauguration du
nouveau siège du groupe socotec
entreprise spécialisée dans l'inspection
et la certification de construction et
d'infrastructures cette société
installée depuis 1979 à saint quentin en
yvelines a réuni ses trois sites
existants dans ce nouvel espace de 7000
m² alors ce nouveau siège ils
représentent d'abord un
un environnement de travail radicalement
nouveau pour les 450 collaborateurs qui
travaillent ici beaucoup plus ouvert
beaucoup plus facile temps de travail en
transversal exprimant beaucoup mieux ce
que doit être un environnement de
travail
aujourd'hui en 2018 avec ce nouveau
siège socotec a pour ambition de devenir
le leader européen de son domaine
d'activité avant de refermer cette
édition 2 information a noté mardi 9
octobre à partir de 17h30 le ski cube
accueille la welcome party l'occasion
pour les dirigeants d'entreprises et les
collaborateurs de découvrir les services
offerts par saint quentin en yvelines
inscription obligatoire et le sky
business day aura lieu le 8 novembre
prochain les candidatures pour
participer à cette convention d'affaires
sont ouvertes si vous êtes une start up
ou une entreprise du territoire
candidater sur le site www.skype.com
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]